hi
i'm anthony d mays software engineer
google and i'm here to talk to you
on the topic of one to more why sharing
our narrative
matters again my name is anthony mays
i'm a software engineer at google just a
software engineer
but i also happen to be a dei advocate
and i think it'd be interesting to start
off by just
talking about what i uh how i became a
dei
advocate in the first place i started
off
my life as a foster kid in compton
after being exposed to physical and
sexual abuse
and throughout that journey i learned
how to be a programmer and
learn how to code when i was very young
began to
become very interested in computer
science and went to the university of
california irvine
to get a degree in that area
i went throughout my career not thinking
that i was good enough to reach a place
like
a google or one of the other big tech
companies
but i always wanted to work for google
and so
after failing the interview process and
then succeeding on my second try
i now find myself a googler and it's
been the culmination of a lot of things
and a dream come true for me and i
didn't anticipate becoming a dei
advocate by the way dei stands for
diversity
equity and inclusion if you didn't
already know and these are things that
are very important to me
which is one of the reasons why i've
become so passionate about advocating
for
more diversity equity and inclusion in
tech
championing more belonging in this space
that has
traditionally been challenged with not
having enough representation
from various individuals and so
i want to talk to you today about how i
do this
how i advocate for a better dei
through something that i like to
describe as sharing your narrative
now there's three things that enables me
to do what i do as a dei advocate
first is just having a strong company
culture
that enables me to do what i do second
is having the support and participation
of
people from from throughout all levels
of the company
that's been very important for me as
others have championed and supported me
in my work
and then lastly this idea of sharing
your narrative so i'm just going to
break each of these down
to be more clear so when we talk about
having
an empowering culture there's really
four things that i think work well about
the culture at google first of all the
culture is
strong and well-defined there's things
that make google's culture unique
um the people that we hire tend to be
very intelligent tends to be quirky we
describe it as googliness right googling
this is a description of the culture
that we seek to have one where
innovation
is encouraged where people work hard
but are also able to collaborate a
culture where you can have fun and enjoy
what you do but at the same time tackle
very
deep and hard and meaty problems and
that kind of culture
is well suited for someone who is
working in the dei space because there
are
so many challenges there's a lot of
obstacles to overcome
and having a culture that that champions
and supports the best and brightest is
important
as part of that trust and leadership is
important and i don't mean managers and
managers of managers what i mean is
leaders people who
are naturally inclined to to find a
problem and see it and want to tackle it
you want to find people who can be
leaders even if they don't have the
formal title as
i don't you want to support them in
leadership
and it's important that when you find
leaders that you trust them to be
leaders and support them
in their journey one of the other things
that's important about google's
culture is the emphasis on results so
it's not just about
saying cool things it's about doing cool
things
and as a dei advocate one of the things
that is important
is that i'm held accountable for showing
the results of the work that i do
in making sure that we're moving in the
right direction
measuring results is important too so
having regular surveys that gauge
employee sentiment
and really understanding how people are
thinking and feeling
is a very important part of ensuring
that the culture remains strong
and then last but not least there are
enablement tools and
in order to be a dei advocate there are
a lot of tools that i need
everything from scheduling and
calendaring to
social media tools to templates to
program guides you name it
there's a lot of tools that are used
in the work that i do to help me be
effective and it's important to have
quick and ready access to those tools
oftentimes i'm not
needing to ask for permission to use
these tools
i'm just encouraged to use them and to
use them responsibly and having that
kind of
freedom that enables me to be very
effective as a dei advocate
now in addition to the culture another
thing that's very important
is making sure that everyone is helping
to drive change
you know in a culture it's not just up
to one or two people
to decide how that culture is going to
be every time you add a new person
to the company every time you add a new
person to the culture it
impacts the culture and it's important
that everyone understands that they have
a role in place
uh in this discussion and in this change
it's not just
up to black people such as myself for
instance
uh and when you don't have a culture
in which everyone feels encouraged and
empowered to participate
it places the burden on those who really
seek and desire maybe even need change
to do the work
and that's not healthy one of the
challenges of being me
being a person who happens to identify
as a black man
and as a christian is that there are
there aren't that many of me in tech
at least not yet and it's unfair to
place all of the burden on
change on the people who are the least
represented or who aren't
well represented furthermore it's
important for everyone to understand
why you want more representation why you
want more inclusiveness and belonging
so that everyone can buy into the same
vision going in the same direction
now one of the things that i believe is
very important
towards helping us achieve this goal is
the idea of the narrative
and it used to be called diversity
narrative you can call it that or
belonging narrative however it
is but the idea of the narrative is that
it is a story
that fleshes out who you are that it
really fleshes out
not just who you are but why you care
about diversity equity and inclusion
and i would like to think that the
narrative reflects the things that don't
show up on your resume
right a lot of us have skills and
qualifications that we know make us
suitable for executing the business
tasks that we are assigned to execute
but there are other things that inform
how we
are the way that we are these are
attributes and qualities that we gain
over our lifetime that
inform the technical aspects of what we
do
and it's really about as martin luther
king said once
the content of your character and we
want to have
a good understanding of how our
character is shaped the way that it is
and
how it is that we relate to other people
and how
the differences that we bring most
importantly inform how we make decisions
uh whether in a team or on a project
so that we're able to build one another
up
and this is really about making sure
that we've got
a culture of belonging right where
everyone feels like they have a part
in the discussion where everyone feels
like they have a a part and a role
to play and that they feel like they're
part of the team in helping to achieve
the right results in today's climate
where you have such
underrepresentation it's common for
people like me
who come from a non-traditional
background to sometimes feel excluded or
to not feel like we belong as we should
and i've talked to many people
who have had that narrative of the over
the years whether it's
a woman who's a software engineer but is
treated as though she's a project
manager or whether it's a
black person who is misidentified
or any of those other things you know
those kinds of interactions cause people
to not feel like they belong and as a
result of that
sometimes when we chase diversity before
inclusion
we end up making this revolving door
effect where the
diverse people that the people from
diverse backgrounds that we hire
end up walking right back out the door
because they don't feel like they're
part of the organization
and so narratives can help build more
representation
and more belonging more specifically
within the organization so that people
who
are hired a new talent that comes along
know that they
are part of the organization that
they're part of the team and that they
belong
and can do productive work and so one of
the things that i think i do
more than anything else as a dei
advocate is to
empower other people to share their
narrative
to open up about what makes them them
and
how they contribute to the culture and
to the team
and to doing the things that they do in
a more holistic way
and so this is what brings me to
a special initiative that i started
within google and i'd like to share it
with you because i think
you may be wondering well how do you
share your narrative how do you share
how do you encourage other people to
share their narrative
and to talk about who they are and what
they bring to the table why dei
matters to them i think that once you
understand
how to encourage other people to do that
it can have a very powerful and
transformative effect
as we'll talk about shortly so
i started a thing called share your
narrative within google and what it does
is it provides
a platform and a framework and a space
for people to talk about their
narratives and
i think that it's one of those things
that really helps to scale
my impact as a dei advocate because i'm
just one person
and i want to have as much impact as
widespread as possible
while i'm sitting in my seat and i
believe that the sharia narrative
initiative has helped me to do that
as i mentioned before the sharia
narrative initiative
really is three components one is a
platform
that is built and used in order to
encourage people to first of all
understand what a narrative is and then
two how to share it
two there's a framework and so there's
specific things that make up a good
narrative and we talk about that
and then lastly we provide environment
where you can explore what that
narrative
is and understand how it works and uh
and how you can improve it and make it
better
so first thing the platform when i built
the sharia narrative site it was very
simple it was just a google sites
site and it linked to a google plus
community which is now google currents
and that's really all i needed
google currents was great for providing
a place where folks could post
video articles images as they're sharing
a story from their life
they're able to show a picture of maybe
that time of their life to help
folks visualize what's going on or maybe
pointing to a helpful video
you know having rich multimedia on the
social media platform
is very important for helping people to
to really share parts of themselves that
maybe they wouldn't otherwise share if
they didn't have that kind of a platform
on the website that we have for sharia
narrative it's just a static page
it includes some instructions and faq
really very simple
but it's a one-stop place a one-stop
shop
for finding out what a narrative is and
how to share it and
at google we make it very easy to share
websites we have special links
and so i crafted a special link that
points to the site and made it very easy
and memorable for people to get to
next comes the framework and i'll admit
that i didn't invent the
diversity narrative framework but i more
than hardly use it
now a diversity narrative really is
formed of three parts
first there is the reason why you care
about dei
uh and so you you talk about what are
the things that are meaningful to you
about
improving representation or more
belonging
or those things and you'll just briefly
touch on that
theme and the theme will set up for the
second part which is a story that helps
illustrate why you care about that
aspect of
diversity equity and inclusion it should
be something real something that
happened it can be
something that relates to a business
situation that you've encountered where
you saw
an optimal result achieved because of
dei
or the opposite if the lack of
representation
didn't result in the outcome that you
were hoping for
so there's that story and you know if
there isn't a story that you feel
comfortable sharing about yourself
perhaps it's something that you've
noticed in another situation
that didn't directly happen to you that
made you think about why dei is
important
certainly the the events pertaining to
george floyd has caused many to to not
just hear about but also see
some of the reasons why this work
is important and impactful and so you
can talk about that
in your narrative and share maybe a
moment from your life
where it really hit home for you and
then
the last thing that i'll talk about in
the framework is a call to action so
you'll have the purpose yd matters to
you you'll have the story that connects
to that purpose and then lastly
some call to action and the call to
action is super important
in the call to action you want to make
sure that you're inviting people
to join you in the work because
hopefully
in parts one and two you've inspired
people to to understand
why they too should care about dei
and if they're ready to act you can
provide them a way to join you in the
work
the last thing that the sharia narrative
community does
is provide sort of a safe environment
for people to share
their narrative and to feel supported
and so they
manifested two ways number one there's
someone who reviews the narratives
for spelling and grammar and just to
make sure that things are cohesive
and succinct then once someone decides
to post within
the google current community other
people can
like on those narratives or share their
comments and support
support the people who are writing and
from what i've seen it's always been
positive it's always been
good when people post these narratives
and are able to say hey i connect with
that
one of the other unique things about
specifically using google currents is
that
in our community we were able to sort
posts by a number of different
factors and so if you were writing a
post that focused on
why age representation matters you could
categorize your post that way or if
you're talking about
race or gender you could categorize
those and then it gives the community a
great way to be able to see
the narratives from these various axes
of diversity
that one may care about now our
community
is rather small it's just 156 community
members
and growing and i'd say that's not bad
for a software engineer
but if those numbers seem small i want
you to think about the multiplicative
effect of sharing your narrative see
a narrative isn't just shared within our
community oftentimes it can be
included in an email link it can be
shared during a team meeting
it can be spoken in an off-site used
during a speech before a great technical
presentation
there's any number of ways that you can
do that even just sharing with your own
family or friends
by sharing your narrative you connect
with other people
and help them to understand why it
matters to you and if they care about
you
why it should matter to them as well and
so
the narrative has a multiplicative
effect my own story about
my journey to google from compton was
featured in the buzzfeed video
that had over 5 million views and
certainly
it's probably safe to say that hundreds
of thousands of people all around the
world have heard
my story and narrative have been
encouraged by my journey as i've given
of myself
to talk about how it is that i came to
be in this space
and how i encourage other people to do
the same and so
there is this multiplicative effect of
each and every single one of those
individuals some of whom are engineers
like myself others are executives some
are in sales they come from all
different parts of google and all around
the world and they participate in this
community and also share their own
narratives
in places that we may not be able to see
and so there's a great
positive benefit of being able to see
these narratives grow and be shared
widely you know this really is about
scalability
right there's only so much that i can do
as an individual
but i want to make sure that i can
empower the next generation to do what
i'm doing and to do it even better
so that we can encourage more
inclusiveness and belonging in the space
now i just want to end with a couple of
final thoughts that i think are
important
first of all understand that knowledge
isn't power
not knowledge by itself knowledge
rightly applied
is powerful and that's really what this
is about a lot of us have been learning
over the past few months about why
the conversations about race about
inclusion
about belonging not just in tech but in
the world
why these things matter it's not enough
just to sit on that knowledge and not do
anything
it's important to do something and
sharing your narrative can be one of the
easiest ways
for you to be impactful in terms of
inviting other people to the
conversation inviting other people to
the work
now even though it's one of the easiest
ways it's still not
easy and i know that it takes you
sharing a bit of yourself that maybe you
didn't plan on sharing it work
and that's okay you're not alone
and one of the best things about the
share of your narrative program is that
it has
shown people that they're not alone i'm
not alone
as a person who has struggled through a
rough upbringing to become a software
engineer beating the odds
there are other people like me across
all different backgrounds and all
different shades
and that's really what belong is all all
about at the end of the day i know
that as a result of this program and
other things that i belong just as much
as anyone else because i'm a googler
and so i hope that this time has been
encouraging to you thank you for tuning
in to watch this presentation
and the best of luck to you and as you
pursue
greater diversity equity and inclusion
in your company or organization
thank you